all six stones I could see to snap my
fingers they would all cease to exist
Tony there's no other way hey everybody
it's Charlie hopefully you've had a
chance to see infinity war by now we're
gonna be talking about Avengers 4 plot
details in potential storylines based on
stuff that we know about Captain Marvel
and the stuff that preceded it so just
careful for spoilers for everything in
infinity war and because the black
panther blu-ray is dropping I'll do a
giveaway for that I'll explain at the
end of the video
but the whole deal is is picking up an
Avengers for how they gonna solve
everything in what does Captain Marvel's
plot in the characters and that tell us
about what they're doing for Avengers 4
because we learned about a casting
notice for Asian characters in Avengers
4 that needed to be comfortable wearing
prosthetics on planet earth so people
are like well that means alien
characters but what aliens require that
kind of prosthetics most of the big
races that we've seen so far are either
motion capture because they're so
complex but because these are gonna be
numerous people of the same race it
sounds like it's gonna wind up being
scrolls the Kree don't really wear a lot
of prosthetics it's really like blue
paint their ears are shaped just like
human ears so when people saw this cast
they noticed you know must be
comfortable wearing facial prosthetics
very clearly if they're gonna have
Captain Marvel fighting the scrolls
during the Captain Marvel movie back in
the 90s it would make sense that they
try to turn that into a much bigger
thing in the Marvel Cinematic Universe
by carrying it forward into present day
in Avengers 4 so a long time ago at
comic-con when they announced Captain
Marvel in the scrolls we had a theory
they might do Secret Invasion for
Avengers 4 and then you know more recent
plot developments the fact that Thanos
comes back and all these people were
turned to ash that they need to bring
back just put us off it a little because
you can't do full-blown Secret Invasion
without bringing all those characters
back you can't do that without the
Infinity Gauntlet you can't do that
without going back to Thanos so we're
still heavily tied to the Thanos
character even though he's achieved his
mission we still need the infinity gems
to bring everyone back and fix the
universe but more recently theories have
started to pop up that because the you
know
first wasn't totally aware of what
Thanos was doing like there's a lot of
conjecture about who knew and which
other big space-based races were
tracking Thanos that was one of the big
sticking points the Russos told us is
that the cosmic forces had not yet
become aware of what the anos was doing
so he was on a timetable for that
finger-snap so now that that's done
people are starting to find out what
happened but only because of the ashes
so what is a big Marvel event did the
Kree were involved in the Captain Marvel
is also tied to the kree-skrull war a
lot of people were like okay they fought
a lot their races have never gotten
along but what if the scrolls blame half
of their planet dying on the Kree and
that ignites a giant space-based war or
the beginnings of one that they deal
with in more cosmic based movies so
whereas we kind of thought that the
Captain Marvel movie was dealing with
the kree-skrull war they might just
tease beginnings of that that they then
later pay off with other movies because
on a recent Disney call the CEO of
Disney Bob Iger said that they're
developing a brand-new Marvel franchise
that is not the Avengers it's something
that's totally new which makes it sound
like it's not something that we've seen
and it has something to do with the
Marvel cosmic universe that James Gunn
has been helping develop recently Kevin
Feige said that he has movies planned
through 2025 that doesn't mean all the
movies just a couple of the bigger ones
like obviously we know there's gonna be
a black panther sequel they'll probably
do a Captain Marvel sequel of some kind
there might be another Doctor Strange
movie another Thor movie you get the
idea we know about guardians 3 the
spider-man movies the whole idea of
Avengers 4 is that as they sort of close
the book on this first 10 years of
Marvel movies and start something
totally different they T up what that
different thing is and it sounds like
they'll do that through some minor
secret invasion storyline plot details
within this larger story about Thanos
the Infinity Gauntlet and bringing all
these dead people back so that's why
when it comes to actual scrolls during
Avengers 4 it just sounds like there'll
be a couple like one character that
we've thought was a human this whole
time will be one and that'll be sort of
the lead-up to the threat that they pose
Captain Marvel also having dealt with
them in the past the other big thing
that they just introduced in the comics
that also sounds like they
might borrow a little bit for Avengers 4
is the idea of the Infinity armor
because Marvel always likes to do big
comic-book tie-ins with the movies that
is doing like it did Civil War 2 the
year that Civil War was released in
theaters right now they have a new
infinity saga that's going on and
they've teased the idea of not in
Infinity Gauntlet
but infinity armor like adding the gems
and wielding them through a suit of
armor so who does that sound like right
now in the movie universe that sounds
like Tony Stark so if the idea of the
gauntlet was is that it was the only
thing that allowed Thanos to wield that
much power at the same time someone else
who wanted to wield that same amount of
power of all the gems at the same time
would have to have another device
capable of channeling that so we know
that Cherie has examined the mine stone
she has a functional understanding of
how the Infinity stones work
Iron Man also has a pretty decent
scientific understanding of the Infinity
stones it would make sense that if he's
going to be the person to bear that
burden to wield that power that they use
a modified version of his armor that
Cherie can probably help him out with
which is one of the reasons why I think
it's important that they left her alive
the Russo said that the people that
survived the finger-snap survive because
they're critical to the plot of Avengers
4 so what does Cherie do in the Marvel
Cinematic Universe
she's the technologists that can match
Tony Stark blow-for-blow when it comes
to designing things so if they need to
design something that's capable of
wielding the power of the Infinity
stones
it sounds like they'll develop a new
version of Iron Man's armor that will
help him do that during Avengers 4 and
that would be part of bringing everyone
back the first big fan OHS war crossover
that they did in the comics was right
after the kree-skrull war and then right
after the first Infinity Gauntlet saga
they did Operation galactic storm which
was a big space based war between the
Kree and the Shiar Empire so it just
sounds like there'll be some big
space-based conflict happening in the
wake of Thanos finger-snap because
people just don't understand what
happened
why is everyone turning to ash did our
enemies do this to us
so who are the enemies of the scrolls if
not the Kree so let me know in the
comments Avengers 4 what do they do to
bring everyone back do you think that
it's going to be as simple as using a
new mod
five version of Iron Man's armor to
wield the power of the Infinity stones
were you expecting something a little
bit different and how do you think that
they'll weave the scrolls into
modern-day continuity because we won't
see them for the first time till Captain
Marvel but it makes sense that one of
the characters that we've seen so far
winds up being a scroll in they do just
a little bit of Secret Invasion
but like I said remember how they jump
from storyline to storyline during
infinity war Avengers 4 is gonna move
the same way so it's gonna be character
moments weaving together a couple really
big action set pieces so I should also
say they've been a lot of theories about
what the title is like I've had a couple
of my own theories the Russos have said
that no one thus far has guessed
correctly what the Avengers 4 title is
so it's still wide open
they said that Avengers Forever is the
closest title that has come but that's a
comic book storyline that involves them
jumping around in time that's probably
not the plot of the movie and they said
that it's the closest but they didn't
say that that's what the title is they
didn't give a timeline for when they're
gonna drop the first Avengers for a
teaser but because they have to start
marketing the next spider-man film in
Spider Man is technically dead right now
that will probably start later this year
meaning there's gonna have to be some
Avengers 4 news
sometime around then too so I wouldn't
expect to hear a lot about that till
well after Comic Con in like October
November sometime around then like think
about when venom is dropping in that
Spiderman animated movie Tom Hollands
spider-man sequel is the key to us
getting more concrete information about
what's going on during Avengers 4
because they can't market that movie
without Tom holla'd and you can't do
that without explaining how he comes
back but do not be surprised if they
hook themselves up some fake trailers
like you know they included that fake
scene of the Hulk during infinity war in
the trailer bore very little resemblance
to what the final movie was that will
probably be the future of Marvel
trailers putting together something
really flashy to get people to come see
the movie without actually telling you
what the plot really is so like I said
there's that black panther blu-ray
giveaway all you have to do to enter
that is be a subscriber and leave a
comment on the video I'll name a winner
the next time I post new Marvel don't
worry we got plenty more that we need to
dig through leave all your requests in
the comments below
but click here for brand-new infinity
war and click here for that brand-new
Deadpool
thank you so much for watching everybody
stay awesome I'll see you guys tonight
[Music]